hello everyone uh well where we have
kevin core with us and he would be
presenting on an intro to workflow
management with brief
and uh the session is gonna be for 30
minutes including q a and please note
that the whole session is governed under
par data global code of conduct and
please adhere to the code of conduct and
don't validate it so not taking much of
a time kevin uh over to you and if you
could just start with a short buy of
yourself that would be wonderful
yeah i have my bio in my slide so i i'll
uh start sharing my screen first
so hey everyone
welcome to
an intro to workflow orchestration uh i
can answer questions during the
presentation since this builds uh on top
uh as we go along so
uh you can just feel free to throw them
in the chat i'll pay attention to the
chat
and
uh yeah with that so welcome to this
session um a bit about myself i am an
open source community engineer at
prefect uh before that i was a data
scientist for four years
outside the work i contribute to fugue
an open source project for
distributed compute which is actually
the other concurrent session
uh and all and then i also run the
orlando machine learning meetup
um so
uh today what we're gonna do is we're
gonna cover uh what workflow
orchestration is uh and then we'll go
over a simple problem and how you would
apply prefect to orchestrate your
workflows and then uh we'll
we don't have a lot of time today we'll
briefly over go prefect and dash
together
and then
we'll discuss the future of prefect
we've had major updates this month that
we'll go over
so with that let's start with workflow
orchestration uh so if you're not
familiar with workflow orchestration in
general you have a data pipeline whether
it's an etl job or maybe it's some kind
of machine learning job where data is
going around and there's like
interconnected components so here we
have a database maybe we're getting a
file from that database we're hitting
some api for additional information
putting them together in the pandas data
frame
and then we train the model persist some
artifacts
spin up a server with that machine
learning model uh if you're not as
familiar with machine learning this this
in general you'll have a diagram like
this for your etl
and inside a diagram or in such a you
know pipeline you have a lot of these
interconnected components right so what
happens if this api intermittently goes
down or what happens if um this
database actually dies and this thing
cannot run
what happens if our model doesn't train
right uh maybe
uh the metrics don't look right or maybe
um the model didn't converge or run out
of memory there could be a lot of
reasons why these things fail right and
they're very interconnected
so we look at the points of failure like
your database going down your api going
down
um like uh like even this api call to ml
flow where you persist an artifact
there's just a lot of different reasons
that are and a lot of them are beyond
your control also like these apis
intermittently failing uh compute going
down these are normally these are stuff
that uh are
out of your control sometimes and
sometimes these failures just happen
and when they do
it's uh
it's it's quite a lot of work to
one work around it but to even if you
were to try to prevent it it takes a lot
of work to
code against
these faiths having code that can handle
these failure paths correctly and as
pipelines get more and more
interconnected
what we have here is a you know a bi
pipeline maybe that shares some common
component with a machine learning
pipeline now we have these
interconnected pipelines that can that
have multiple ways that they can fail
and
if they fail we want them to only affect
their pipeline and not necessarily other
pipelines
and we want them to also be you know
like
um
we we want uh the failure logic to be
handled very gracefully like maybe we
can reuse like old data instead of
fetching if new pulling new data wasn't
available maybe in some cases like the
api maybe it's just a simple retry right
and all of this is what we call negative
engineering so
negative engineering is all those things
that you do in order to get your data
pipelines running smoothly so if your
code worked 100 of the time then you
would not need any sort of negative
engineering but in reality we need a lot
of negative engineering we need a lot of
failure handling we need maybe timeouts
notifications when stuff goes down we
need um you know
ways to handle malformed data or apis
going down intermittently like in the
form of retries and prefect was
uh created because you know you you
often hear like
uh
uh developers spend like 90 percent of
their time on uh negative engineering or
even 80 of their time so in prefect if
it's 90 and we can reduce that to 7 to
80 or 70 percent then in effect we can
uh double or triple developer
productivity so prefix mission is to
eliminate negative engineering
and a bit about prefect uh the comp the
company so so there's a company prefect
is both the company and the open source
project so the open source project right
now has 7 700 plus github stars we have
a slack channel which i personally
manage it's like my job to answer stack
questions
and support our community we have around
10 000 users right now
in in the slack community
so prefect is an open source workflow
orchestration framework that's python
based specifically designed for the
modern data stack right so um it's meant
to really handle the volumes of data
we're seeing today and one of the ways
it does that is a native das integration
so it can scale
to big data seamlessly we have a very
active community
there's a lot of people a lot of data
engineers
a lot of you know people doing very cool
stuff so even if you just want to chat
about data engineering or workflow
orchestration
or you want you're thinking of using
prefect and you just have a couple
questions you want to ask like by all
means just join our community and you'll
definitely get a response
and then
we have prefect has two um
uh two components one is what we call
prefect core
which is the api with which you design
uh your workflows which we'll see today
and core runs with the back end so this
back end is uh
if you use our managed version that's
called prefect cloud and if you go and
spin up the open source version on your
own infrastructure
that's called prefix server so you can
fully do that
but uh we'll also show you why using you
know prefix cloud
because of our because of the model of
which we run things every all the
running happens in your infrastructure
as opposed to our server
and this is a sample of the ui that you
see when you go to prefix cloud so this
is my dashboard read this the failed
flow runs gray will be the cancelled
flow runs the green will be the
successful flow runs and a lot of our
users kind of describe prefect as their
single pane of glass where they can see
all of their
flows and if there's anything wrong with
them this is fully interactive you can
click into these red bars see the
specific error logs the tasks that
failed
similarly you can also click into the
green
runs just see everything ran as expected
we even have people who have been
requesting
prefect on mobile because we do have
users that
have said that they check their phone
every day in the morning just to see if
like there were any pipelines that
didn't run successfully
so this specific month has been pretty
big for prefect the company uh we made
two announcements earlier in the month
and this is like the first
uh conference where we're talking about
it
so number one is we acquired a data
consulting firm called slate data based
in chicago
and this acquisition allows us to
provide better enterprise support but
the
also also really big is this
announcement of pre prefect orion so
orion is what prefect right now is in
version 0.15
orion will basically be our 2.0 and
orion has a lot of like
breaking changes based on of of the you
know previous three years that uh where
prefect you know supported people in
their workflows and realized that there
were a lot of fundamental things that if
we could uh you know work around then we
could provide a much smoother developer
experience for
uh building workflows and so i'll also
uh show orion later on right now orion
is in technical preview so you can go uh
spin it up try it out yourself uh it's
open source as well
uh and it is
pretty different from any other
orchestration framework out there and
i'll explain that later
so first we're going to see the current
prefect core
so now we have this this uh orion and we
have current prefix core pre the one uh
for production workflows today you would
still use prefix core as a rhinostone
technical preview and prefect core i
mentioned this in version 0.15 we're
steadily going to make that a 1.0 pretty
soon after we stabilize it
just a bit but i mean it is very stable
it is used by a lot of companies in
production workflows already
so for
our motivation today what we want to do
is we want to track dogecoin prices and
we just want to be alerted when there's
a dip in dogecoin price
and when i was preparing when i first
prepared this talk uh in the death uh
for the death summit earlier in may
there was this major uh dip in crypto
everything just down ten percent
uh it was it's quite shocking i mean i
don't trade crypto myself i don't know
if we have anyone out there who does
but yeah in general we want we're
interested in capturing these like dips
so that we could get an alert
so first we're gonna do this in
pure native python without prefect right
and we have two functions so there's
going to be four steps number one we're
gonna make a url
number two just a simple request for
that uh to get the data number three the
actual check for dips and then lastly
we're going to send ourselves a slack
notification only if there is a dip
so here we have the first function
the only thing you really need to know
is we're hitting the coindesk api
and we are passing in a coin
and this coin will be plugged into the
url
so that and we'll just return this url
and then this get data function we're
just gonna do a get request to that api
and then we'll we're gonna get the
um a data frame
of the results and pass out that data
frame
and then we have our detect
dip function so we just get our data
frame
get the peak get the bottom um
there there will be uh
the data changes every minute
so we will just be getting 10 minutes of
data so just like a 10 minute window 10
measurements
and
we'll just check the max of that the min
of that see if there was like a major
percent you know dip
if there was will return true uh if
there wasn't low return false uh there's
a threshold here so this is like 10
dip that we're expecting
and if you're to put this in production
what you would do is something like you
know create maybe create an ec2 instance
uh make an infinite loop to be run every
five minutes
we're gonna
get our data uh
check if there's a dip and then there's
a dip we'll post to slack so i didn't
implement the post to slack yet because
it's going to be a lot easier in prefect
and i'll show
how later
but uh in general we have this up and
running and again with negative
engineering there's many things that can
go wrong right so like what happens if
the api fails the hitting the coindesk
api
well maybe we could code retries
ourselves right or what happens if we
wanted to track another coin instead of
dogecoin well i had i'd have to spin up
another process change the dodge there
and then
run that separate process
what happens if we wanted off schedule
runs uh besides this three like we
wanted a run now right instead of this
300 seconds well i'd have to go
to that box
uh you know take out this while loop run
another script right so there's a like
all of these are certainly things that
you can work around
but the more and more you do it the more
you're gonna find that you're actually
writing more code to handle that failure
because our our core code here is not
long at all right and more of the work
will actually be done to handle failure
and that's where we can bring this to
prefect to
show how you know we can make this uh
how prefect can handle these for you
so the first one is uh
the
workflow orchestration semantics of
prefect so prefect uh we have tasks and
we have flows flows are comprised of
tasks so you can think of tasks as just
like a python function
and flows are a group of tasks right so
basically more like a python script
and in order to bring this to prefect
all we have to do is decorate this with
a task decorator and now this is
something that can be brought into
prefect
and then we a while ago we had our loop
so now we just change it to this flow
object and we say with flow as flow and
we have all these tasks that are called
and and then we can run do flow.run to
execute it and there's three important
things here number one is that if you
look at this there is a first class
support for passing of data so data will
become a data frame we pass data to this
detective so we have we can pass data in
memory from task task and this is a very
pythonic syntax
this is still the original code we
didn't really change it
right we just wrapped our test decorator
around it
number two is that there's an automatic
setting of dependencies so when you pass
data to this detect dip task
detect dip will realize that get data is
an upstream task
and
so prefect will create the dag of the
execution dag for you
and the last thing is local testing so
if you do flow.run it's just like
running a python script
you get your output and a lot of other
orchestration frameworks they'll require
you to spin up certain infrastructure
whether that be like kubernetes whether
they're tied to kubernetes or whether
you have to spin up the the server the
database etc just to test your flow in
prefect it's very seamless you just do
flow.run and you run your flow like a
python script with the additional
logging that prefix provides
and then
we have an api call here if you remember
what happens if this goes down because
apis can just you know
occasionally
uh return
uh
occasionally fail
so in prefect all we have to do is add
the max retries and the retry delay
so this will try up to three times this
whole task will try up to three times
uh
with a one one minute uh delay between
each retry and now we get retries on
this task
the next thing is what happens if we
wanted to track some other coin well
remember that my get data task
took in the dodge parameter here now i
can parameterize my flow on the flow
level and my task logic doesn't have to
change
by
uh making this parameter called coin and
then i could just do get data of this uh
of this coin parameter that comes in so
during runtime we can plug in you know
bitcoin or ethereum instead of this
dodge coin and the whole flow would run
for that specific parameter
so what parameters is also one of the
strengths of prefect it's a very
uh intuitive interface it's just like
python basically
there's no ginger templating or anything
like that
uh and here we can experiment we can
also do flow.run with added param with
different parameter values so
here i just do flow.run with the bitcoin
and now this whole flow logic will run
with that
the last thing i said is that posting
will we want to post to slack i told you
that this would be a lot easier in
prefect and that's because we have the
task library in prefect so you saw what
tasks look like and because they're just
python code what we can do is uh we can
make a library of just you know these
api calls
like for example uh the database uh
calls are pretty straightforward
normally you're just passing in a query
into the test and then you get some data
out
so mysql postgresql like we have these
uh tasks written for them so that you
can easily just do that like databricks
submit job
maybe you want to upload to s3 so we
even have people who are not as familiar
with python but through the task library
they're able to construct flow like etl
flows because a lot of the standard
connectors that they need are already
present here
specifically today i'll be using the
slack task
in order to send myself an alert
so i'm going to import the slack task
and i'm going to provide this message
there was a dip in doge price
and i provide this webhook secret so the
webhook secret is a secret uh that i
store on prefix cloud that's fetched
during runtime that contains a link to
the slack channel that i want to send my
message to
and then we can just post this to slack
uh we can call our post to slack task uh
which is this one that has already been
configured
uh so yes uh the secret is just this
this is the name of my secret we're
gonna pull it during runtime and execute
the task with that secret
uh so a while ago we had this
conditional logic this
red highlighted code above is our
previous like non-prefect code we did
this if if there is a dip post to slack
uh in prefect we have our own if else
task called case so if uh with case if
the dip is if is dip is equal to true
then we'll just post to slack
now
with that we know that all our logic is
complete we just need to register this
to
prefix cloud so we provide
flow.register and a project name and the
project name
is just like for the ui there's some
separation that flows belong to certain
projects so we're just providing a
project name to attach it to a project
and as we register the last thing that's
important is a schedule so
uh
schedules we just want to run this flow
at a given schedule so we can construct
it for us we just want this every five
minutes
so we'll do an interval clock every five
minutes with doge as the default
parameter
and then we create a schedule and attach
the schedule to the flow
and now when we register this schedule
uh
the schedule will be applied
and with that we're gonna do a quick
demo uh over here
um so i have my
prefect cloud uh ui
um and
it's gonna load
uh
so so there's a question here in the
chat in the doge example why do you need
with case instead of using a regular if
yeah i i understand so
here the the question is over uh here
why do we need uh the case and that's
because if you use the python if
it's not a task
and you need task uh you need to use a
task for it to have deferred execution
to bring this logic into runtime right
so in order to do that we need to
implement our own task that sim that it
gives that if else behavior
but
with prefect 2.0 you can use the python
primitives you can use the python if
else you can use the python controls and
uh it's very very like the the
development experience even more like
it's just a great writing python code
so
uh over here what i'm gonna do is i'm
gonna go to the
pi data
actually i my internet cut off earlier
i'm going to refresh this
so i'm in my pi data project
and i have my flow here that we just
worked through together and i registered
it
with this flow register pi data so i
attached to the pi data project
and
now what we have to do is we have to
start an agent
and this agent
lives on your infrastructure pulls
prefect cloud every 10 seconds hey is
there a float to run and if there's a
float to run it pulls that flow down
or not really down it's more like it
finds where that flow is stored we don't
store it for you and then it pulls it
and then it executes it on your agent so
all the execution lives on your
infrastructure and this is one of the
biggest reasons why people use prefect
so over here um
in our pi data project
we have this uh flow registered
and i'm just going to give it a quick
run
oh i'll go to flows
it's this to the moon flow over here
and now i'm just gonna hit this quick
run button
and you should see there's gonna be a
yellow bar the yellow bar is like
there's a run that's been created it's
scheduled now and then soon enough it'll
turn blue blue is running so our agent
picked it up
and then our agent deployed it run it
locally
green means it was a success
and last you should see that because we
had the slack task i have a alert here
that there has been a dip in doge price
i mean i i
set the threshold very low for that to
happen
uh so we're nearly out of time so what
i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
not
what uh not show the desk stuff but we
do have like a native desk integration
also that allows for parallel execution
instead i'm going to show what
prefect
2.0 will look like and 2.0
we have this flow decorator so it was
this was created to be more uh number
one there's a separation of build time
and
in current prefect you have to build a
dag and then during runtime will execute
that tag but in orion 2.0 there will be
no dag no pre-registration
because in a lot of ways the dog was
confining people to to have you know
very static workflows and now we're
going to transition to having as much
dynamic system as possible and part of
that is as you mentioned
mark mark andre
where why can't i just use the python if
here we have
the python for loop that we can just
loop through loop through and then
execute this task right and we want we
want to provide like a very python
uh you know friendly developer
experience and i'm nearly out of time so
i just have a couple links here uh in my
slides that i will be sharing uh
definitely check out the orion release
and our press release around it uh if
you sign up for prefix cloud you get
free uh 10 000 free task runs every
month it's way more than enough to get
started with we have a lot of hobbyists
who just you know use the free tier
and run their workflows that way also
feel free to join the prefix slack uh
we we definitely like we will if you
have any questions we'll get to you i
will respond to you
uh and with that uh i think i'm done and
i can take questions
i have uh two questions here
uh
number number one is
is prefect like task scheduling uh like
salary plus monitoring
so um
think of it this way
airflow there's airflow right and
prefect uh like uh it's like a you know
next generation of like that kind of
scheduler so airflow can use celery as a
task queue
to do stuff in parallel prefect uses
desk right so desk would be our
equivalent task queue and we would
provide uh the observability around each
of those tasks that run on top of of
desk uh so salary is more like a
distributed task queue whereas prefix is
more like a uh a batch level
orchestrator but the batch level
orchestrator can live on top of like
this like task queue
number two how will the transition to
orion from prefect work so the
transition we do have a lot of people on
current prefect current prefect is not
going anywhere anytime soon it's gonna
you know
be until like 20 end of 2022 at least
and then transitioning to orion we will
be
producing a lot of like migration
content for that um and in it should not
take long like
it should only take like two to three
hours to transition like from prefect
like for a real project to transition
from like current prefect to orion
because a lot of the stuff is still
there it's just the engine and internals
that have changed
uh
yeah there's another question by tom
what does the upgrade path look like for
folks who have uh
current prefect uh to like orion um
that's that's uh
same thing as i just mentioned it
shouldn't take too long there's a lot of
similarities it's the internals that
have changed have become more flexible
in a lot of ways it will also enable a
lot of people to do stuff that they were
struggling to do before with dynamicism
i have a question from tin uh how can i
use prefect for my aws data lake
pipelines
yes you can uh and we have uh you know
built-in tasks for that so you can just
like fetch your aws data in some way and
then you can persist it i don't like if
you get it from a database you persist
it in the data lake after some
transformation that's something you can
run on a schedule put that you know let
prefect manage that for you for sure
florian said a big fan of prefect
of course uh i mean florian is a member
of our slack community uh looks like it
will solve many pains we face for
production code yeah
all right thank you thank you for the
kind words flareon
all right thank you kevin uh this was a
wonderful talk and i think we are almost
at the time
so thank you kevin for joining us today
and it was wonderful to have you
yeah thank you for having me i'll see
you